яскравіша Звісно ж лялька як
персоначи як тренер знайомлю що що таке
лялька Звідки вона взялася яка вона я не
показую цю ляльку потім саджу педагогіку
пово діти е увага там у нас там буде
заняття Хтось прийшов і коли я виношу цю
ляльку Ну от позавчора у нас бу навіть
не Вау а отак отревали педагоги вони
вірять навіть в цю ляльку лялька 70 см
пропорції тіла у неї як у дитини ну я б
сказала навіть семи-восьми років не
шести голова - це восьма частина тулуба
Вона вдягнена ми її передягаємо вже уже
цілий гардероб кож кожен тренер для
своєї ляльки взяв Ну і Ця лялька
знайомимо дітей що вона приїхала там з
Угорщини Там хтось з Києва в нас
приїжджає на кожному тренінгу по-своєму
і лялька не розмовляє з дітьми вона на
вушку каже виховати угу угу добре я
зараз розкажу
дітям там Катруся алуся манюся вона
приїхала хоче з вами привітатися
познайомитися ви бачили наших
вихователів вони з нею вітаються
ірокаються а питають можна заручку
потримати Але у нас наш тренер завідувач
дошкільного закладу міста костянтинівки
вонапробувала вже на дітях адже в неї
тренери це базовий діт садок у неї Лерка
вона не втрималася пішла до дітей і
нам же ж цікава ж практика як же ж це
відбувалося детина спитала а чи можна
щоб Лялечка ця посиділа в мене на ручках
Ні вона не хоче на ручках вона Ну вона
ще тільки приїхала вона ще дітей
боїться така технологія дуже цікава для
вихователів і саме для інклюзії адже
можна піднімати це як підготувати дітей
до прийняття нової дитини в групі це
проблема батьків батьки не хотять знаєте
як мене Нана вона така Іде вона знає вже
там і турецьку і німецьку і взагалі
танцює співає все вміє і читає все а тут
прийде дитина Ну там з синдромом Дауна і
вихователь буде відволікатися на цю
дитину А як же мені тут Я б сказала Ця
лялька навіть і туди піде мабуть і до
батьків і дітей підготувати до
сприйняття особливої дитини що
запропонували вихователя що лялька
потрібна не одна лялька потрібна на
возику не Моу лялька потрібна з обличчям
синдрому Дауна і навіть сказали Ну може
там в окулярах нам потрібна ще ще
вляльки такі потрібні щоб саме проблема
формування цього інклюзивного простору в
дошкільному закладі сприйняття особливої
дитини такої як вона Ну як всі щоб не
було жалості так що дякує за таку цікаву
технологію Запрошуйте ми приїжджаємо ми
скрізь мандруємо проводимо тренінги
дякую